[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
also hello everybody and welcome to our
Monster Hunter livestream we're playing
Monster Hunter generations ultimate on
the Nintendo switch we have a special
guest with us today we've got Mika
Burton hi make up thanks for coming in
and playing Monster Hunter this is one
of my favorite franchises we love matzo
runners thanks for coming by and we must
got Ben Janka who is our resident
Monster Hunter here at GameSpot huh
thanks for being taking part in this
anytime anytime you need someone to make
some some pants on monsters okay as we
will so this is all brought to you by
Monster Hunter generations ultimate and
we're gonna be playing through the demo
today the full game is out on the 28th
but we are playing the demo there's
three monsters that we're taking on and
we're gonna have Myka and then jump in
now and take on the first one so there's
three of varying difficulties that
correct there's a little bit more about
this demo so they give you a beginner
fight intermediate fight and an expert
like the expert fight is against one of
the flagship monsters which is like
literally a jet dragon yeah it shoots
lasers out of its Rangers it's a real
real piled spectacle but we're gonna be
fighting kind of like a smaller Raptor
type monster okay who still a dick
though oh yeah
it shouldn't pose much of a threat but
for some reason it still manages oh yeah
yeah so I'm hunting with the aerial
fighting style which the fighting styles
are a thing that's special to the
generation set of games so I can like
air hike off a monsters and do all sort
of stuff with that and Myka who are you
playing as I'm fighting with a charge
blade and I think I picked Stryker I've
been playing world a lot so generations
is a little bit new to me I will admit
my generations new penis because I kind
of came in the world and went hard into
world I think I have like some stupid
amount of hundreds of hours in the game
that's all but I am getting used to
generations I know that everybody who
looks at me they're like why would you
put the virtus whoopin charge way to
charge outsource or Luxor Church is so
stupid it's like I'm just pretty bad at
it makes sense to me for some reason so
forgive me for all the monster hunter
like absolutely have been playing it
since one people looking at me and being
like god no but I'm doing my best
there's a lot of people that are just
jumping into Monster Hunter this year
yeah myself included and yes it seems
pretty awesome and so world seems like a
really good way to like get into it and
now we've got the switch like we get to
play Monster Hunter on the switch what
you know exciting when world first came
out I remember thinking I would love to
have just any of the franchise on my
switch I know it's on the DS but there's
something about the switch that's a
little bit different yeah I just want
everything almost my yes so I'm pretty
happy to see a franchise that I
definitely love and especially like I
said I have hundreds and hundreds of
hours in this game so with flying and
traveling and convention we're in good
hands here that yeah it's it's something
that's fun to take on the only thing is
I can't play it in public because I
crumble so so the cool thing about this
game is the the local co-op is pretty
sweet which we're doing right now so
we're playing on two switches Ben and
mica are playing together local
multiplayer and I'll be jumping into you
can play up with up to four players
total so I'll be joining as well as the
cat as a feeling I don't know you know
if um kind of like in world the more
people you have the heart of the monster
is is that I think it's do yeah because
I know that's why I play a lot but since
our first monster I'm excited to learn
more
yeah I know it's a big draw of Monster
Hunter it is the fact that it's co-op
but I'm like stay out of my game I don't
want a hard monster please also if you
are hanging out with us in the chat I'll
be taking questions for Mika and been on
YouTube so check out our YouTube and
leave your questions there and I will
ask them while they play right correct
please please get rekt please go to
house get Rex please pretty please with
cream and sugar could you please fall
over and die thank you crying has a
question on YouTube Nico what's your
favorite monster my favorite monster is
the engine ass because he's a he's a
t-rex yes
also the armor is amazing I have a
friend who told me she's like whatever
monster hunter armor because she loves
making armor and which baffles me foam
work baffles me but she's like if you
want monster hunter armor I'll make it
for you so I think they were gonna
collab with her and I need a heal I can
do antonov armor which is a cape and a
cute like bikini top and it's it's rad
that would be so cool yeah if you guys
are not familiar with Mika she is a
badass cosplayer who's got a lot of cool
cosplay so I'm really excited to see
some ups or hunter cosplay from you it's
gonna be fun I also I love oh you're
running away of course bye see you later
I love having a tiny little girl hunter
with like a sword twice the size of her
so I'm gonna try and get into that even
though I don't like cut with a great
sword I'll probably have a great sword
what I cosplay Monster Hunter what's
your favorite monster yeah then what's
your favorite monster so I think it was
for that they put it in but there's
there's this monster called the the
gormogon and it just it looks like this
like dark the boding like it's it's like
black and purple
and it just it's it's like a weird snake
dragon thing but it looks like oh so
that's that's definitely one of the
strong points I think of this series is
the monster design and true that the
armor design oh right so it's really
cool in this game because I think this
this is like a like a greatest hits
collection again but it has like the
most monsters of any of the monster
games all they're just to kind of like I
got home there's one of my friends who's
like a monster hunter aficionado he let
me look at his monster hunter art book
which is like 500 pages of gorgeous
beautiful armor and armor and I have
found some armor that even though it's
not like maybe some of the most
recognizable Monster Hunter armor and
and monsters that I definitely would
want to cosplay one day you mounted it I
didn't leave it alone then so I won't
knock him off you off yes so it was the
game before this were it would not be an
early oh yeah that's kind of a silly
choice yeah why would we do have another
question from second crease Myka what
draws you does charge blades I really
love the weapon sight but like you
mentioned there's a lot of push backs
with other hunters
um so because I used to play like I'm
not like a fighting game kid like I
could never compete it like competitive
fighting games or anything but I used to
play like Soul Calibur stuff yeah okay
so things like combos and things like
changing forms like IV IV zwip to sword
you know stuff like that
that's kind of what draws me in I also
love versatility when I'm doing anything
like fighting and hunting which is why
when playing like Final Fantasy
specifically 15 I loved playing as
noctus because you can have a prince
your lamp you can have your guns you can
have your regular sword you know I like
versatility and I also am impatient so I
can't play games like like
Dark Souls or something because I can't
use shields I want to go in and slash at
people's ankles until they die so I need
something speedy like a sword but then I
also need something heavy hitting like a
freaking axe so charge blade dick gosh
just turn it up over here like jump
around right okay
okay you're just tuning in we're playing
Monster Hunter generations ultimate
we've got Myka Burton here this is all
brought to you by Monster Hunter
generations ultimate and we're hanging
out in the chat on YouTube so send your
questions in and I look at those ask for
you let's see what's going on in the
middle today you got him for a sec I
think he might be running away okay
perfect timing Hunter % calculated
totally point only when play about the
entire time I knew he was gonna do that
um so Monster Hunter expert question yo
teach us teach us look at that I'm more
of a I'm very new to generations these
arts
down hit so yes another new thing that's
special just for four generations tell
us about that they kind of work like I
use like a fighting game analogies sort
of like the don't like special moves and
in like Street Fighter or something
great so you build them up by either
using the special kind of function of
whatever style you chose or just by
hitting so like for instance I'm using
aerial but I've got like a regular one
that's just kind of tied to my longsword
uh I'll do this like kind of like sword
swing and
for a hit and if I kind of knock it'll
actually give me max spirit meter for
actually exact amount of time but it
just kind of gives you the general buffs
or will be a really strong hitting
attack or will make your next attack
like super strong but they're just like
a little extra layer of stuff you can
kind of do I'm trying to figure out
exactly what happened so absolute
evasion is pretty cool I do like a spin
move away which I could have used there
I'm gonna leave for a second I'm gonna
die yeah absolute evasion I think is one
that is you can put it on any style but
it gives you a uh-oh
leave me alone
we knew that flute evasion - go away -
get out - get out leave this area
completely to leave the game I'm
actually now in her world but it gives
you more active frames on a dodge which
is really nice I think you can actually
do a follow-up my turn attack mode - oh
that's cool so that's that's a kind of a
good thing
yeah give you a little bit of extra
strategy some get very good fight on red
yeah I definitely want to I can't wait
for the full game to really delve in
learn the arts pick my fighting style
you know yeah and who knows maybe I
won't be a charge play person or maybe I
started with dual blades those my first
dual blades are a lot of fun weapon
I actually like so I played a longsword
most of the time and then into world I
played our switch axe
mm-hm and then messing around on this
demo great sword kind of thing all right
so it's kind of nice to mess around with
all the weapons what we change is how
the game plays oh yeah
oh he's limping you see Joe please take
it away
I'm sorry you sure are you really
feeling it look at that shield it's so
cool I love the shield turns into the
axe like that's what's so cool about it
run right that's awesome
if someone else in the chat was talking
about how that she was like tell us
about that shield that's crazy
if Derek looks like one of the ninja
turtle it does well hello hi my dude I
came in here and you just dropped it on
top of me oh I need to move I need to
move I need to move watch out
I'll be joining them a bit later for the
second and third monsters I'll be
playing as the feline which we need
because as I was saying earlier gonna
play my I'm just gonna run around and
kill you guys yes definitely need that
I'm so aggressive I forget to eat we
just get caught up in the moment
yeah and then all of a sudden it's like
you fainted and you're like oh what who
me why I need to use the web plates or
stone stepping I need a sharper blade
[Music]
so as we mentioned the full games coming
out on the 28th this is the demo and you
can play against three different
monsters in this demo and you can get
that for free available now but if you
want to pick up the full game on the
28th $59.99 you can play up with up to
four players and also it's really fun to
do the local co-op so get some friends
together you can choose from 14
different weapon types mix and match
them with unique hunting styles and
hunter arts or even play as an adorable
but ferocious feline which I will be
doing very soon
so ferocious so vicious this makes all
these cute meowing sounds actually it's
like not scary at all and also some
really bad cat puns I love a good cat
fun I'm here for the cap I love palico
so much he's not a real sleeping boy
over here
oh oh real sleep boy take another taking
a good little man always taking a snooze
oh oh oh okay always the time particular
no I'm gonna say you you wake them up
with with a good assault yeah alright
waking him up we're gonna we're gonna
transfer into that and then we're gonna
we're gonna just get a little bit closer
and we're just gonna oh he was not happy
with his alarm clock so the best is the
best kind of alarm clock oh no it's time
to get up with the blades of the face
the best part of waking up is a blade to
the face that's what they say best part
yes absolutely
Daniel Lopez says it's awesome see Myka
here so what is your favorite part of
this new game version love you on
Twitter I'm just excited like Ben was
saying all this it's like the best of
monsters collection so we get to see all
of the cool monsters at like maybe I
haven't seen before because I haven't
you know been in the Monster Hunter
world no pun intended that long so I'm
excited to see some cool new monsters
crap some cool new armor that maybe I
haven't before no don't don't look at me
don't look at me I'm not here don't look
at me
oh I saw that happen do we hit each
other
there's long swords notorious for for
being a pain for anyone who's not using
the long sword it's like I picked like
the the best possible thing to to mess
with you while we're doing our first
time wonderful
thank you tell us a little bit more
about the hunting styles or under
Earth's so there are multiple different
styles that change up the core gameplay
for the weapons work so for instance I
was mentioning I'm aerial style so I can
instead of doing a regular dodge my
dodge now is this like somersault that I
would have done if I weren't doing that
but you do like a somersault instead of
a dodge nice and if you somersault onto
the monster like this you can watch up
into the air and changes up
I was not paying attention I was not
paying attention or you can use a style
that gives you access to more of the
hunter arts there's one that is more
grounded in like regular Master Hunter
without having too much crazy stuff at
it I just jumped off of the thing that's
fine well no wait for you at camper oh
no you're far down yeah pretty far down
I can climb up we're good all right
there come meet you there I did it so I
can heal all part of the plan
kai and YouTube said Ariel style for
charge blade and switch access the best
really I should try out that size yes
it's really fun it's it throws you for a
bit of a loop so for instance like with
longsword the main thing of it is the
the spirit blade combo and you can't do
it on the ground you have to launch off
of the monster before you can actually
do it so it makes a lot of the main
stuff kind of focused on watching
yourself up into the air
[Music]
but when everything comes together it's
a very beautiful thing all right
he's run into area seven area seven news
you might be trying to eat yeah probably
I'm on my way does it heal itself so if
it runs loose area it'll come over to
these these eggs okay it'll try to eat
one of them Oh
which is where he was heading Oh all
right I'm jumping off into the area I'll
be there in a sec
[Music]
so think that's a we were talking about
it earlier that's interesting about
generations is I'm not used to loading
screens yeah everything's still kind of
segmented out we had that zones before
because technically this is like a like
a TS game which it is yeah and you can
load your 3ds oh wait let's do this
no so yeah if you played generations on
the tree yes you can actually transfer
it over at least two easy.all - there
you go now here we go
well done it's only 1147 with you're
going to play for about 15 minutes
because I I have a feeling that the last
one is probably what's gonna give us a
lot of trouble oh yeah we're gonna need
a lot of time for that lively all right
so you got through the first one we've
got the second and the third one so tell
us about the next monster we're gonna
take on so it's like a mix of like a
saber-toothed tiger and a wind okay it's
okay yeah you find it out in the snow it
makes ice tornados that'll freeze you
it's it's a pretty cool pretty cool dude
and he likes to fly around a lot Gosei
yeah play again I'm gonna try aerial
style I think I will do I mean you know
it's a good time oh you're gonna join
soon I was joy yeah I'll just be a cat
all right should I stick with the same
weapon or should I try something
different
oh do you try sticking with it I was
sick with it it'll probably work out for
you I'm down I might do a glass or
insect
the mountain monsters aerial we're gonna
we're gonna see how this goes okay
you said he flies around so yeah there
you go you gotta you gotta stay in the
air too nice
so how do i doing you guys so Doolittle
go away yeah find yep
so what medic they actually back up to
pick you up because I think we confirm
losing our party oh I'll back out I'll
back out so you can play this with up to
four players so now we're going to try
with three players with me be support
weight back out further oh okay sorry
guys no worries all good tell you what
I'll do I'll restart the game I was
gonna say or yeah here okay we're gonna
just what I'm let's bring it back in
will get this set up the right way yeah
let's go full screen on us and just take
some questions I mean you're setting
this up my account and my girlfriend's
account she's like I don't need to buy
switch if you have one I'm like this
very true so I like putting her account
on my switch so people are asking what's
different in this compared to Worlds
there's a lot more monsters
yes there's says the largest cast of
monsters for any game in the series whoa
that's I think it's over a hundred what
proper determine expand favorites two
mysterious never-before-seen monsters
that's pretty exciting and technically
they're like because there were four
flagship monsters in the original one I
think there are two more in this so
there's six like six flagship monsters
or something in this very secure
password love it well it's all something
so they'd have to be in the building to
join okay perfect oh you've done it
those giant bomb boys will never be able
to get it so know they're sitting
outside the door and we made it we did
it we did it so proud of us all right
yes here we go cat intermediate we got
this
[Applause]
rats crime said do you guys feel bad
about killing monsters and can you tell
us about the new hunting style folks I
think all monsters should die in honor
of my boots little thing and like we
gotta make blue pants yeah you got a hot
war monsters to make better pants it's
like listen your life stands in the way
between me and a matching set of armor
thus you must die so I'm gonna say ah
that's funny I think I felt bad like we
were talking about funny fighting that
one chicken monster yeah yeah I forgot
it's like the teeth see something so
it's it's that weird yeah it's a weird
chicken one yeah or is it the cooler
Yakub it might be the cool yeah cool I
think it's been a while since I I try
not to fight him as much anymore cuz I
don't I don't necessarily need some
pants but see here I grab this a
barbecue spit so what are we doing here
we're just grabbing some supplies we're
grabbing supplies out of the side of the
supply box yeah we're gonna head out and
we're gonna fight this guy he's all up
in the top o snowy mountains where are
we going I feel like oh this way okay
yep did it if you guys are just tuning
in we're playing Monster Hunter
generations ultimate with Mika Burton
brought to you by Monster Hunter
generations ultimate and we're hanging
out in the chat on YouTube for a bit I'm
joining them now for the second monster
I'm playing as the feline and I'm a cat
along with the hunter style stuff like
outside of changing how some of the
moves work it'll actually change the
properties of some of the stuff so for
instance I'm using this this bug Lance
right now normally you can use it to
pull the ball top in your car look oh
why would I be aerial style when I can
already
ergo pull the ball up into the air but
what it does is it changes the pole
vault so it's more of a forward motion
whoa the dodging is jumping now yes so
you get oh yeah so you to do that you
you kind of like probably do it on
just kind of like jump at this guy I
should let you jump off of them yeah
press an attack and come down on top of
them it'll change how awesome your stuff
works that's really cool I like aerial
style hairstyles real real fun cool oh
I'm into this sorry yaks Daniel Lopez
says what monster would make the best
pair of pants those there's one what's
it called it's it's like the pal of
Paulo Paulo me yeah the Palamon yeah
which way am I going so we can climb up
the stuff these rocks over here okay and
follow see you the palu its armor set is
very chic yeah it's real real puffy real
cool we plan on putting out some some
good vibes when you're wearing that one
yeah oh I'm pressing keys live idiot I'm
climbin here comes the cat there we go
there we go
switch controls are different than Xbox
controls it's true you gotta get the the
button placement down yep so it's a real
real exciting time so we're going into a
cave I haven't fought this monster yet
me neither I've been practicing on a
beginner like seeing a little wimp wimp
so he's he seems like he might be kind
of intimidating but he's he's not too
bad
well there's three of us I think we got
this it's real a real chill dude
but um Bob not proud of whatever
welcome to punch stream doing it we're
doing it all right it is quite icy in
here
there we go all right where is this
monster boy Oh him that's what we're
fighting this guy all right hello gonna
just up the tape there we go saber-tooth
dragon Wow
t big t big t big the real big but Oh
Ariel style is so fun I'm gonna go buy a
frozen tag
I'm already ice know I'm a snow cat help
you out of that wait oh thank you much
stuff very thank you I was frozen come
back here I'm trying to go bleep I want
to leap I'm gonna be so distracted just
by jumping now this is a puzzle it's
such a good time I'm glad I can see your
health bar so I can know what I've got
to play that born like a healer I watch
where you do it again I did too I am
again a snow cat once again and I'm back
out took my head in the game
oh he's speedy I don't like that he's
such a speedy boy oh oh that works I
mean good Jing my guy come back here get
over here okay I can see why he's gonna
be a little bit more of a problem
I think Errol was a good choice for this
dress you guys made the right call there
hey my dude we wanted to land so I can
fight you thank you
oh there we go alright I'm a snowcat owl
okay and I'm out of the stone
every time I change my blade and get
slow he may help
oh there we go
cool I mean you still cut stuff off of
other than this one yeah so it's still
still can prioritize cutting off tails
and breaking off parts and get you bonus
I'll turn it on in detail thank you
neither that
oh that's so cool
I think I found my official new style
boys girls words that Errol is worth
that did shout to the guy in the chest
yeah
cool around dragon rate I really want to
get better at projectile weapons like
I'm so bad at all of the bows and guns
new stuff same there's always like that
that one weapon type of you kinda wanna
like break into a aerial style is
actually really fun with the other range
weapons could you do a lot of like you
flip off the front of them and they'll
be like shots oh that's cool like almost
like which I'm excited for by the way me
too Osborne
I'm just excited for my trash boys gone
too narrow to just be trapped all over
again
the doctor is looking looking kind of
rough for now that is looking down and
he's looking I would say distinguish a
good decisions lemon Dante and they were
looking like my my still favorite trash
son yeah
love Nero so much gotta love them and I
keep walking into this ice big dumb cat
idiot I was a small downcast
man if he could land so I'd lands and
hits on him that would be that would be
great it's so cool yeah I can just stay
on the ground oh man
no why do you hate me mr. drag stop
moving I swear
oh my goodness
oh look at you you're so angry no okay I
want him to stay still
oh that's a mountain that's a mount for
sure alright keep him here keep him down
keep him down yes he's thrashing around
he's not happy not happy there you go
now he's down there we go there we go
get him get him going it going and broke
it oh yeah how's that feel how does I
feel now that you're grounded I'm not
followed by my last predicate I'm not
hitting the tail like I should I'm sorry
I'm dumb too I'm too into like she's
doing this we just got so we got tail
fin we got real good nice don't bring
back filled up doing it
alright going for the tail go for the
tail okay okay oh he's bringing in all
of us get your friends and riders yeah
party
oh boy exhales Lance I heard that crunch
yeah that's sound of me getting tail
slaps oh no I'm dizzy
oh I'm dizzy to shake it off is you
together shake it off shake it off
Oh trying to go for the tail but he's uh
alright there we go there we go there we
go there we go there we go stop moving
you garbage feed
always flying away oh no come back where
have you gone before to go where to go
where to your hood off to Zone seven all
right hey at least that means we've done
some damage yes he's afraid right not
having a good time yeah you run this you
better got you better run oh here he is
Rachel gave me some I'm guessing this
game is on the switch yes it is this is
on the intent of switch you can play the
demo right now if you want to after the
stream of course the demo is a great
opportunity to mess around with the new
styles and everything to kind of get a
handle on it especially if you're coming
over for the world so I highly recommend
that if you're interested in Monster
Hunter there you go sorry I'm forgetting
my etiquette as well but I saw an
opportunity to go underneath and it's
all done yeah
they'll bring out the swarm there yeah
bring down the hammer or the axe if you
will I'm just under his butt go for the
tank that's a good way to do it
I mean you know we flew a he knew about
you where is he is he gonna have you
guys taken off all right we did some
serious damage that dude he's afraid
okay let's run this way meanwhile
there's like a Yeti throwing snowballs
at us it's really exciting someone
finally showed up to his it's like I've
been here alone this whole time I've
been waiting for you another runaway
he's like what guys was trying to eat no
you don't know you don't those paralysis
nice oh oh
[Music]
God having a pallet it was so much
better so much any of these last two
bosses would be pretty tough Oh
oh wow what was that he's done it more
intense Rory huh oh there is I just saw
his face it's not a pretty is the face
only a mother maybe that's why he's so
mad sitting out here secluded in the
snowy mountains nobody loves him he'll
never find love kitty because look this
is the worst monster stories to come up
with need some help but listen just
because he's ugly doesn't mean he can be
mean generally
oh sorry it's okay okay that's a really
good thing about playing as a pallet go
is that they actually have nine lives in
Santa Cruz
yeah so when you as a pallet go
you don't actually take away a cart
until you get part of eight three times
I think that's awesome so it's kind of a
nice little I think that's best
if someone in the chat knows better than
me the chat oh I'm running all the way
back to camp and run I'm frozen I'm a
frozen bubblebeam
stop raising me
Oh No
that's right into that they did not do
that dodging into his eyes right into
the tail that's that's probably not the
best this is a very good idea
oh yes spikes to the face my favorite my
way up the mountains man this is a long
road ahead will stick hang in there
oh oh I did a thing sorry
Oh God say I can knock you out
thank you gotcha I'm gonna pop over here
it oh he's on top sir he's got to do it
yo all right at least I got some mist
it's alright
oh he's definitely here yo yo alright he
knocked me out
that's fine Oh transformational gaming
said I want to follow me on Twitter
what's your Twitter name my twitter is
at Mika Burton everything I have is just
my name there you go
I'm easily branded it's funny as I
started doing a like more overwatch
stuff and everybody had tags I was like
I want a cool gamertag but then I
realized I go by Mika chew on Xbox
that's like the gleam I like say we
handle thank you what are you doing over
here
stop stop being sneaky
let's do this I'm into uh shark my blade
it's all good I'm inspired now yay right
back yeah welcome back you're some
health thank you
take that
being mean to my friends yeah that's
true shoulder charge right
I see take it off again there he goes
always flying I love the shadow circle
yeah yeah that's helpful
there you go all right I haven't need to
use a whetstone at all like this hole
right that's rule for weird I'm so used
to every 30 seconds like acha hold on so
go we've dropped a little bit we need to
bring it back up because it really
matters like if you're can you get out
of corner please I don't want it you
know what Raconteurs yeah Oh James she
came for me
like what you app so heroes yeah I
thought I was being courteous how did
you still have his tail
I'll during a push down a lot of hard
streets that needs a letdown that roars
powerful it is
oh I walked into that that's the time
these were what's down Internet
oh I can't use it while I'm frozen
please here we go how'd you go thank you
yeah yeah hi got real windy totally ten
minutes ten minutes left
he hasn't even limp yet take him down we
got a fight harder he runs away from us
but yeah if we got to get him limping
ha
Oh
don't knock me off don't lock me up door
knock mouth
jiminee help them hurting a little bit
just kidding I dunno
lately it's okay it's okay I'll run back
No Oh campus farm
yeah it took me a while I climbed up the
mountain
all right I'll be there as quickly as I
can
my better ego defensive oh yes very nice
hopefully that'll get it
[Music]
young
how does this monster compare to some of
the month of the world
this one reminds me of the pallet I keep
forgetting a little clue stones in
Palermo that one only because of the
fact that it flies around and has I
think it's shouts done me yes it's got a
real real angry roar yeah and he doesn't
land often which makes him frustrating
very much
and thankfully in hives
big whiffs
we're able to take this monster down by
yourself it uh yeah it was muster on
earlier last night just to kind of like
get back into it I got him I didn't beat
me oh I couldn't allow the expert oh
yeah they were at trouble with the last
one yeah the difficulty also definitely
scales because I could beat the first
boss monster in like ten minutes by
myself and then we we had ten minutes
left
doing it together yeah
I'll be honest I hear you
all right
although it moving
[Music]
oh no we stopped all over me where you
going
oh the double on shell
could you not could you not thank you
very much
stuff friends here too they're not nice
oh wow somebody could smack me or he
smacked me thanks dad it works that
works that's fine
thank you
man
one angry boy kipper bug Scouts two feet
away from the monster seriously perfect
okay oh I need help desperately
yeah oh no kitty
get up
let's run away again there yeah thank
you
all right I think it's headed off to
seven yeah okay
let's hope he's limping oh wow he's his
how long he's a real tough one well now
we've gotten our bearings if we have to
take him a second time I feel like we
could do it a lot better definitely
he's a little close to his own change
yep I just popped out Marky said Flash
bugs are great for dragons who fly a lot
we have that room I don't think they
gave us any in the box our reps
yeah I don't think we got any which is
real unfortunate
oh he's hurtin a little bit
five minutes whatever five minutes doing
it doing the things this is in the bag
we've got it we got it we got it we got
it
really no yeah I think we just did a
whole bunch of damage so much that makes
sense doing it all right okay five
minutes guys we got this
where's first five just knocked me into
a different area that's rude all right
all right knocked myself and dude we're
gonna say he did it oh he's eating stop
it
stop anything yet no snacks for you
it's the last kind of extract I want
can you please stop with the eating
thing
and the yelling thing on it and the
icing thing oh my goodness so hurt that
works
- tit is that your bug yeah it's taking
his time he's not it's not real if you
want it today it's real cold though not
today how that shoulder charm is really
oh thank you
and he just negated all of that with his
stupid George George
[Music]
and when they get hurt they get a groan
of let's do this this is where this one
we don't know yeah that's that's the
good stuff
that was it up stuff oh no kitty rip
yeah thank you there you go
oh don't dive at me thank you
Oh we'll just land on me why down here
kilo my weapon powers super degrees and
I have to whetstone
I'm a trouble
[Music]
managed to do that without getting hit
come on Washington you didn't even keep
them from falling we'll just skip it no
kitty
thank you careful that shoulder charge
it is I got smacks oh oh he's laughing
he's limping no no you can't believe
this
we we're down to the wire where is it
going okay we've just gonna have done
this where is he gone does a copy of
jump this okay it's checking on the chat
all right yeah it's not he's not taking
a nap he's not taking a nap is just a
special guest today and as a we'd love
to keep her but she's here to play Potts
our other generations ultimate brought
to you by monster many generations
ultimate so we're playing lovely the
coop right now all three of us we can
play with up to four players this is the
demo which you can get right now but
it's also for
it's coming out on a plate
I'm gone
right mate oh man do we boat faint do
that I fainted automatically oh it's
okay okay with your bring it back this
is a chant this is a learning
opportunity this is this is you can't
you can't win a hundred percent hunt you
go on it's true it's true so what do you
do you pick yourself up okay try again
we want to try to show you Jenny never
do I want to stick with who we chose
stick with the styles we chose no change
on my weapon a bit I'm gonna stay with
healer cuz I feel like that's we
definitely need that yeah I wanna stick
with my blade only because I'm just
getting used to it yeah that's fair
that's that's totally good all right so
I think I'm gonna stay in the center hub
do i do play again or no yes oh yes yes
nightly sleep so don't despair try try
again
yes we will exactly well Katie turn
maybe all to our he'll pull us which
acts out yeah yeah okay what what's the
long sword like do you think I'd like it
it's it's pretty fun there's a lot of
like the main combo that you do is all
on this button and then it's how you
power it up single charge blade yeah
basically except it's it's more just
just hitting stuff I guess
and it's precise straight you know what
apologies if I force up get it but I'm
gonna try the long story I'm gonna try
something new it's all about about
trying new things and see what's up
sticking with Ariel because that seems
to work pretty well
my duh cuz I'm trying depth if you're
gonna do charge blade I feel like we
don't need to charge blades so Brady
Higgins said I don't think they give you
tranqs for the demo right that's they
don't know yeah we can check the box
though
yeah they don't give you a Trank stuff I
tried to grab some earlier and it wasn't
be there
see I'm gonna take the first egg man I'm
just taste bark you spit some Romney
there shock traps so there were flash
questions in there I was just looking
for the wrong stuff
Johanna I'm gonna leave you to take the
paralysis knife and the flash bombs and
stuff all right
should I take anything um take a
cleanser okay
so you can remove ice from your body got
it sounds good
so I I realize now that I faked the
charge way I thought I picked the switch
axe oh this would be a fun time well rip
here we go here we go do our best is my
weapon of choice - not a lot of people -
up in those do it but it's it's a bit
complex are you gonna be okay we're
gonna be we're gonna be just fine we
have time to go back back out and switch
we're mixing it up and you didn't even
pick Ariel you true so I went with the
the adept style which is more about
getting precisely timed dodges off Oh
so it'll be a interesting time there's
not the style for me
someone asks you favorite controller on
the switch do you prefer playing on the
pro controller or them do the joy Khan's
work fine
I actually I've been ok on the door with
the joy cards yeah I think either way is
fine I'm enjoying the pro controller I
don't own my own pro controller which is
ridiculous I should really invest in one
get one but I'm so I'm liking it
especially for Monster Hunter I can't
wait to beat that person on the plane
who like the Bulls at my pro controller
and kickstands my switch and I'm like
you know I'm just playing some monster
it's a really cool thing when we were we
were on our way back from e3 I was on
the same plane as a bunch of people here
and we were they all pulled out their
switch and they all started up like a
game of Mario Kart and one of the flight
attendants like stopped doing their
check and just like watched over their
shoulders
waiter so the race was over there like
no markers oh my god we literally become
those commercials look at make fun of
the commercials at first and then you
realize that it's it's super easy to
just become exactly what it was I pulled
out my switch at a party before I've
been like Mario Cart anybody would like
the tiny joy condoms like yeah yeah
everyone the switch commercial first
came out worth playing switch it up do
that mean why I mean you never know
you switch just change things up it's
true and man I wish I have gameplay
right now you're like well I've got a
I've got a switch and you just pull it
out of your purse and you're like how
convenient
I had a Animax but I was playing like
Mario Kart with four people by a pool
and I literally felt like a stupid
millennial commercial and that's awesome
like oh yeah this is normal we could
tell they played this game by the pool
it's a little more stress oh yeah I
don't think anybody's anywhere want to
be near me while I'm playing this so
it's not as many combos I'm noticing
yeah so the main like regular tax for a
long sort can kind of infinitely okay
but the main thing you want to do is
especially since your aerial is when you
jump off and you kind of a full meter
yeah but that's underneath your truck
this okay is press r1 and you'll do the
the main combo which will actually
increase the
attack poly without that so is it mostly
just the X button to attack and then you
build up your meter and then and then
you just launch off and then the press
r1 basically just spam r1 until you do
the last hit okay are there any more
combos as you know about or is it a
pretty simple weapon well it's pretty
simple
okay I'm still used to charge bleh that
I'm like what are the million things
that it is yeah
if you guys are just tuning in we're
playing Monster Hunter generations
ultimate this is the demo the game comes
out on the 28th we've got make a Burt
veneer helping us out we're playing
local co-op with this game you can play
with up to four players and this all
brought to you by Monster Hunter
generations ultimate monster iron I'm a
frozen cat right now
I love that it just makes you look a
little snow so my cat right it's cute
though I think in the world would I at
least some excuse snow can oh yeah and
the Palika armor is so cute I spend so
much of my adorable are like my stuff on
my cat rather than on my own armor
I would do this name all right I'm
spamming r1 when it doesn't match what
why is nothing happening see because
your aerial style you have to do it I
have to be in the air coming from here
so you have
Oh God I'm briefly charged there we go
fries please
I'm free please thank you
what's the horn do I think it's another
he'll sweet
oh I paint it okay maybe picking a new
weapon loosens the best for the
intermediate nodes
I admire your your willingness to do it
though at least we get to show people at
different weapons exactly some variety
probably gonna go back to my trusty
chart playing yeah I feel bad that I
took a trim you know I totally thought
I'd pick the switch oh no it's totally
fine
I'm learning something new we're all in
from here yeah almost out of healthy
eating something
all right
isn't that what the demos about and what
the stream is about to show beautiful
new things
yes things this game can do they don't
just want to see one weapon and me you
know being okay at it they need to see
me sailing up some stuff too yeah
[Music]
Oh landed right on me
and in Section five a penis
I am appreciating this armor though
that's really cool yeah but the sword
matches it yeah it's a real good look so
like as much as people like oh it's
stereotype and so ridiculous I do love
me some good titty armor good times it's
good time this was nice oh my goodness
it's like catching y'see attacks me
whenever I play my horn oh no and now I
fainted
it kills he knows he knows now it's a
Cobb that's that's the healer yeah
healer
I mean any smart play or attack today
with her burning car in life I got an
aerial cat body I'm trying to aerial
and running
got a question in the chat about the new
hunting styles what do you know about
them then oh they're the the variants on
on how you can actually play different
weapons so for instance I'm using the
adept one right now which I'm not
actually showcasing very welcome had an
opportunity to to get a good time dodge
off like so prints since this one is if
you time your dodge just right you'll
get a much larger more active
invincibility frame like dodge that will
let you actually follow the
counter-attack you can have the aerial
style which will let you hike off with
monsters into the air and come down with
a special attack
oh yes third time's a charm
their turn attract yeah that was just
that was just a small test I'm going
back to charge on the charge boys you're
gonna go back to the intended web yeah
yeah yeah third times F an intron good
good test run guys good stuff yeah
just showing off some new stuff in this
game yeah just wanted to show you guys
also worth mentioning most regenerations
does not mess around
yes it's unforgiving a real challenge so
get in there and do your best
oh yes play again
and if you're in the chat we're over on
YouTube I'm taking any questions that
you have so let us know got anything
there we go that's what I'm looking for
there we are
what did you intent a bit off switch axe
so switch accent sharklet at the two
that I use the most in the world I think
because switch acts changes into the
giant sword so I can cut off tails it's
it's a real real fun weapon yeah
we're also on periscope I'm going to see
how it's going over there oh here we go
people are very excited to see you there
like Myka that's also dad punks is this
the demo yes it is this is the demo and
you can get this on the switch right now
if you want to all right I'll pick up
some stuff too all right now
everything's the way it should be this
is this is what we meant to do the whole
time yeah I've got this really cool
looking bug armor going on it's really
rad there's a lot of glowing bits your
wings yeah one of the coolest armors uh
it's not very useful for me in my play
style but it's the one that looks like a
butterfly oh yeah it's so cool
though like just good-looking sets that
I wish that you'd kind of like like use
more effectively sometimes yeah totally
worth collecting for sure definitely
this is the kind of game that you want
if you're that weird completionist like
I need to collect everything because you
will be playing this game for a thousand
hours yeah if you like want every armor
set especially because the desire meter
is a thing in Monster Hunter 200% so if
you want that one that one scale from
that one monster you're gonna be playing
for our different everyone yikes
and so it's how it works sounds like fun
though yeah sounds like a ride but how
did you get into Monster Hunter oh you
know your first game the first one like
I played the original ones with the
first one I actually like got into was
try on the week which is a weird one to
get into because it was the last game of
head under water fights old white which
is not a thing that
and you should too in a monster hunter
yeah especially when the main control
form is a Remo Chuck Oh No
but I stuck with it and then I am
picking up about 3 ultimate weight that
was my roommate a lot and into for four
generations
I didn't play a lot of generations
admittedly but I'm real excited now that
I can kinda like jump into into this one
a switch yeah built in immersion look
all of the monsters so many monsters and
if you go so much better and
wait wait so much a world like like
everyone else
great whoops looks very good
I've heard multiple people say that
world is like one of their favorite
games of the year so far
Oh 100% yeah
I believe in you guys got this where are
you going it's fine around sharp
everywhere
we want to not do that Bell knocking on
the back
10% health
[Music]
thank you yeah he totally know this
really decks me every time I see that
woman over there
I hate music hates music and happiness I
back out real quick cuz I need to heal
oh I'm behind I was stunned and I
couldn't move
yeah I'd like to [ __ ] sorry no worries
I'll be right back okay I'm getting a
little too aggressive there I was happy
to be back on my weapon
[Music]
I like that the palco just
unceremoniously dumped you onto the
floor gone out another one just adding
on to the pile issing end
I always feel so bad for a pallet coke
is in the world when you accidentally
talk to them like when they're just
sitting in your camp and they're like
did I do it okay Johnny I was staring
like you don't even don't even question
it
he's like I can stay here you don't want
me to come on the next fight like you
are the light of my life
and I want you to leave I wish there was
a way I could like give him treats and
just tell him that I love him but he
knows he knows yes haven't that seen up
into giving the world to or they reuse
them and oh yeah we got in the canteen
and we're so happy to see you or both
running around for isness well I got
this get me hello
okay it's time for the air horn
[Music]
I'm watching her screen while I'm
running back and I hate when you're
about to do a combo and he moves and
you're just swinging it in the oh dang
Nemo
guess I'm here alright I'm one section
away
that's when I get really intense in the
monster Shandling alright he's moving
ready to go over to six Wow
he's leavin I went the wrong way um I
just followed you hurry I'm gonna go the
other way
for shame whoops but I also don't want
to run into him by myself well I'm gonna
all his friends are here
oh hi I'm sorry I didn't I did I just
followed my face hey come over here come
out of the zone don't sit in the zone
yeah dodged it
he's sitting in the zone again okay
[Music]
man
he's in dire straits oh no kitty
how nice that shoulder charge is so
nasty get it
I feel really quick yeah do you think I
will keep them occupied crime so it's
easy to learn hard to master
always
stop with the shoulder charge
everyone can enjoy on
[Music]
it's awful when you let stunts lock to
you and he just keeps you in one spot
yep with me did he slapped me it's
alright as I was feeling will stay will
stay safe
pretty sit nice hit
stop it Dodge Bob's got the heartache oh
I'm gonna have to heal
Oh oh man I in the middle of meeting so
maybe that obviously was actually for
single-player not not for a multiplayer
I guess so yeah so I guess if if I'm
player one
what I'm looking for Oh single-player
ego plays a palico in single-player I
seems unnecessarily difficult I think we
kind of tailor the fights for it more
okay all right Brady said definitely
going to have to get used to zoning to
heal and sharpen again yeah yeah yeah
there's there's a lot to kind of you
come there not being able to move when
you heal is a real real one to kind of
get get with again just boning me yeah
it's yeah oh oh yeah yes cool back the
whole animation is kind of kind of silly
and that you you drink it or you eat it
and then you just kind of pose right but
yeah you've got a flex after you heal
because of course is it because yes why
wouldn't you
[Music]
we'll bring it back you were doing
really well on it it's I think that was
one of my eight my original go to so I
kind of I got that one kind of kind of
unlock all right all right guys we got
this party better this is its annual
this is for real for real real this is
it though I don't - because it means you
don't have to fight a jet dragon at all
sure it's true because we do have about
23 minutes left in this stream I'm good
without fighting lasers for eyes yeah
Sam but we're gonna get this we're gonna
get that running at this monster this
saber-tooth wyvern is dead that's right
Kress you said you can hit your friends
though the ice yes you can and thanks
for joining us he said he just got here
thanks for joining hope you just joined
we're playing monster hundred
generations ultimate this is the demo
and the live it's live now if you want
to get the demo on switch but you can
get the full version on the 28th and I'm
a cat running you screams okay I'm here
to heal and maybe the chat and be
adorable cat he's so he's so cute
like I love Japan for many reasons but a
big reason is because they're like okay
so you're gonna fight monsters have this
awesome armor also cats with you you can
put them in all sorts of media the
antonov armor for calicoes is my
favorite because they look like little
t-rex yeah they're so precious
excuse me monkey he's chillin he was
there waiting for me when I was climbing
up the mountain Oh
oh my god a monster just knocked me I'd
climbed all the way up
wasn't that a stupid moment monkey just
no all the way off and I went flying all
the way to the bottom he's a he's a
douche bad he was with it [ __ ] for me oh
hello goodies just waiting
I love the oh [ __ ] music
yeah like the oh you've you found it
it's here don't know how you could have
missed it oh hello I just got punched in
the face as my greeting I jumped off of
your head say I hope you don't mind I'm
done seriously joint there we go
it was the most wolf of an interest the
face he used to be the springboard look
at that Oh mounted to a good stir oh
he's mad he's yes he's very pissed oh
he's already going to another attempt to
throw me off wow it's real quick
sorry gang's all here it's cherry to
knock it down yep it's gonna go in with
my energy blaze
oh yeah take energy to the face eat it
eat it
slicing mark how the field
Gill's Batman kill Batman now you're the
one who is wolf
you know I would probably hate getting
smacked in the face what that leads to
yeah
there we go now in our cooking now we're
cooking with gas all right there we go I
really
so the cats are really cool kind of
option that are on there I'm kind of
surprising even let you play as a cat
yeah I didn't either I didn't even know
it was an option yeah I think it's
because they just want your palate
though to be so ingrained and just there
to help you as your buff you know
but you can play with what is it like
the organ it's kind of like being a bard
yea orsa form to play out cool songs
yeah I do like that kind of every D&D
class almost as representatives of
Monster Hunter look you can do it with
the a bard stop moving let me way out of
there he's like ah like I see you duck
at us how many weapons sales are in this
version of a female gun
pause so I think it's six all in all we
added two more for the new updated
release six weapons are six with flight
guild styles
so how many weapons are there in total
it's nice to be working that back
they're not not counting different
weapon types kind of mix-and-match with
unique I'm in sales and under arts
knocked me right out of that aerial
strike
Oh what is going on a lot a lot is going
on that's a process right now but we're
doing well I think I think we're doing
better than we were before
I'm getting actual hits on them with
like heart attacks
and so is he on me oh no I was trying to
knock you out of it thank you
oh did you get that vent air hike and
then he just runs out of the work it's
really rude it's like I'm trying to stab
you oh and then he was in the middle of
my special move and everything Oh
please let me just jump onto your back
there we go
hit me yeah oh no I never do it I need
to get out of here I need to heal so bad
I'm in trouble
I
[Music]
that was just like oh oh oh wombo combo
it's kind of watching you like [ __ ]
across the whole thing
yep he smacked me across and then I was
like oh I can heal if I walk away but I
was stunned and then he was like as well
time to kill ya
[Music]
just got out of it
I just went away hey if I can knock him
down he's already taken off though he
left all right I'll meet you guys at
6:00 right now it's good I do appreciate
that the stream switches to your
gameplay Ben when I'm just running
through the fields it's all good
good job John Luke in the booth mention
for us your real bro ah you're my time
underneath it okay thanks and no help
careful
terrible that's pretty much definite
monster I know when you're in the middle
of it it does everything's terrible and
I'm dying
everything's going bad all at once
[Applause]
[Music]
there's that one section I don't know if
they have terrain quite like it in
generations but in a world where just
existing and it hurts you yeah so think
normally actually this you'd have to
have oh really that's awesome yeah I
love stuff like that cuz yeah there's
the auger on Armour or something like
that that prevents you from getting hurt
in that situation but it's just I love
little details like that where it's it's
pretty good your environment actually
matters gonna put this down here this
might help there we go
I just got out of being frozen Thanks
come on over here it's really nice it's
definitely not a trap that's on the
ground we'll try and bait him over there
oh no oh no moving where's the trap
Oh
oh where you are yeah okay oh I see it
hey hey [ __ ] I do look look over here
pretty hunter nice oh he walked right
past hey look look at me I'm a hunter
don't you wanna sit on me or something
right over here yeah yeah nice yes you
stupid animal training door truck just
like we planned
conveniently it's not like we baited you
at all up he's gone he's mad so mad
about that
oh you stopped my energy blaze Nene
oh we're both dizzy and we're at and
you're out of it snipers hello hello
what was that flash ball nice
now he's the one who was stunned she was
when he was flying player do you have
any more stunts
I'm so used to the energy attacks like
taking them down yeah
it's just making him mildly angry
oops
come on come on come on get up oh yeah
thank you
okay
I'll take the that's why I mean -
I need to pop over here real quick and
[Music]
yeah there we go
no comeback
where did you go just going back to
eight
all right I think we've we've gotten
some serious damage on it though I think
yeah we're doing pretty well yeah we
stunned him got him in that trap why
does your protocol so angry he's
stressed out that old buddy I understand
it's gonna be okay I think he's eating
weird one of these
Oh what's he doing I'm just setting a
trap under him oh yeah you want to stop
him from eating you know your that's the
perfect timing
an energy blade hope you didn't want
that tail why is it still on I've been
hitting it with everything I have very
it's a very resilient table it really is
little vicious what I really wanted to
cut off is his shoulders so he can't
show their charms
explosion
[Music]
the first-aid med plus is really nice
Oh
thank you gotcha
they're over second yeah
what's gonna eat some steak because I'm
low on stamina so I need a back up in
bed I think he didn't come for me though
yep
compressing spoke dodging into the jump
three
he just keeps moving got about ten
minutes left in the stream but we'll see
where we're at
seems closer or not
somehow managed to just barely dodged
that and we got the mouth yeah yeah
gonna use this opportunity to just
unload all my energy charges on him
[Music]
now
whoa I'm presently
thank you I just stood still look
somebody will hit me potion what pocus
it's not enough are you back off
[Music]
please don't look at me please don't
believe these don't look at me
sharpen up here - same all right you
said getting better guys keep at it
we're doing it I'll be there one second
for sharpening oh I think oh god stop
with the charging of the shoulders into
my face time left ten minutes
perfect same for us - on the stream
we got this we can do this he was
already trying to eat which means he's
hurting right yes so he's not having a
good good time to cigarete
not really enjoying himself
Wow that's it I love poem without the
online subscription yes yeah that is
correct you can just play get some
friends together up to four people
you can play locally without subscribing
six okay I just got on a full health
there's no need to pose I mean after I
have a healthy snack imposes yes celery
haha delicious oh he started off my ode
won't recharge he's so
although to be fair there are three
people or two people in a cat they
trying to get you in so fantastic thanks
Daniel thanks Daniel
Thank You Daniel whoa would you stand
still so I could jump off your back
please that monkeys just wait there for
me every time she's still bad that
monkey has a vendetta against cats I
mean he hates I'm pretty sure that's
what it is Oh got it
I just stand - ow that's my shoulder
every time every time
all right I really I'm gonna I'm gonna
heal just because I want oh don't you he
did the thing thank you moving
soft jumping around great like there's
many single chip a tooth grats we're
doing it ones once who did it time great
and yet this tale his Hill is untouched
still resilient
[Music]
I'm trying to hit him with the ass but
he just keeps moving
Oh trying
thank you
so the most important question you're
playing that the horn over there to heal
us but what what - and are you actually
playing what musical melody is the
musical melody of choice it's clearly
the entire collection of Careless
Whisper
I was gonna say I wouldn't heal my
friends oh no I need to not be the same
though oh man
so the only logical thing to do at this
point since we have like what five
minutes left
yeah do we want to at least look at the
chat dragon to see oh yeah yeah the
dragon definitely yeah
I'm an informant it's at this stream but
let's take a look at it and see how fast
it wrecks because it's actually it's a
really cool alright we were getting so
close you guys I'm so proud of us I
promise you it's not easy yes no and
this is my first foster home this is it
this isn't my uh my character or my
great sword valor style that's why it's
so aerial right OH
or should I go a striker you do aerial
again if you're feeling in strikers
still pretty good oh I'm feeling the
aerial all right
I'll be Disney Princess analytical nice
close-up and scream in just a few
minutes but we're gonna take a look at
the very last months if you check it out
and then can you double yourselves on
your switch today if you want to
take your friends beat up that
Sabretooth Reverend take it out for us
yeah kill it for us please yes it was so
mean and honestly kill all those monkeys
specifically young you one that keeps
knocking me real jerky hates cats
I don't why we're grabbing all this
since we don't really it's not gonna do
us a knot let's go all right all right
even then I just wanna see what it looks
like right this location is so ominous
yeah but the ruins scared when he likes
to hang out it like the most scenic area
- its got like steps and like of course
he does this is dramatic yeah
oh thanks Brady's at first Mansour how
are you doing great sweetie don't get
thank you hello that that's understood
look at that I totally see it in my mind
thank you Oh Oh really boy I've been
want to go near it
that is a mean boy I don't hide what if
we left it alone
do these I stab it I just it's this
chest glowing yeah so he'll start off in
a normal phase like this uh-huh and then
he'll get angry and start to glow red oh
you just you didn't take this one down
right I've taken him down
I can read the Jessie's demo by not not
since then and not easily as the
nineties he's I don't laser beams in his
wings that's scary
Wow look at that glowing chest look at
that angry boy go and he's doing a thing
where flies around as a jet in the sky
now and he's gonna come down and oh my
god oh oh my god he just seems to me so
bad he's a jet he's a dragon jet no no
no what does in the Monster Hunter we're
we sat down and what guys okay okay wait
you're me the dragon but it's a jet
let's listen for a paper what else she's
got just shoots lasers up right away you
know what it's it it's it's it's double
yeah yeah you got me with the laser
oh yeah suck it oh oh he's mad oh oh I
shouldn't have said we're going nuts on
this thing and go over by a couple of
minutes but it's fine
hang in there with us cheer us on
we're gonna die that's gonna be fine
watch it's like defeat my little right
it was gonna say like whatever actually
speeding that would be incredible he's
jumping around a lot less than snow
douche
the the real tell is gonna be if we
actually get to the point Murray it
changes over oh there's another form
this is real sorry for the view
everybody's getting right now just his
under care that's that's how you know
you're doing the best you can I can't
see anything though understand awesome
oh I'm gonna die my goodness yes there
that was
it's got a really good theme oh yeah
this is a pretty epic
[Music]
I have heard of byung-ho tastes just
flying around again oh he's just in the
air oh god no and I fainted
hit the deck apparently I can jump off
and just diving that's amazing
did I dive into the right place that's
pretty
[Music]
are you kidding
I had like a fully charged but he said
today bring it back again climbing a
mountain all right I'll be there in a
minute
apparently I think it takes a while oh
here we go this is white dragon and
except oh that's amazing so surprised
it's okay we're good oh yeah oh yeah
just eating and flexing a picnic yes
okay well then here's a horn he hasn't
heard of a chicken face have you noticed
yeah does he yeah well there we go the
mouth yeah we got a house yeah this is
good as beating him we've shown it we
did it we mounted him oh I was gonna do
such a cool move that's such a dick move
there we go there we go all right
coming in
yeah here we go we got this we got this
guy's
[Applause]
oh there you go it's the underwear is
fine but remember your cokes oh that was
rough ouch
he's literally a jet I'm so confused
[ __ ]
oh please don't I can pack them to the
other zone okay I got to carry do with
my charge moves and it just moves me
over I also he switched over into his
rent mode so he's really angry now
Wonderful's mad oh yeah hi
he looks like you how's about to make a
really bad Dragon Age joke
does anybody play Dragon Age I was gonna
say looks like it's Larry I'm all over
heaven
yeah actually maybe that's what he is
that's the crossover we've been looking
for I would love that well cuz monster
honor does amazing crossovers they did
an Ace Attorney a card captor soccer
crossover I would love for there to be a
dragon it's awesome oh no guessing
that's not a good Oh No the dream is
dead the dream is dead
alright well that wraps things up thank
you so much to Monster Hunter
generations ultimate for sponsoring this
stream and thank you me good for playing
with the [ __ ] thank you for having me
I forgot it's always good to get
stressed out I feel like I need to go
take a shower and like get a massage my
heart is racing well where can people
find you you could find me it says right
there at make a Burton that's my
everything that's my Instagram
that's my patreon that's my Twitter
that's my yep that's all the things that
I have and thank you Ben for helping us
out today thank you but you can get the
game on August 28th or get the demo now
and check it out and avenge us please
kill everything on our behalf because we
tried but failed alright thanks guys for
watching see you next time bye
you